тому що ця діюча влада його привела до
його позиції і ця діюча Влада по суті
чотири роки його покриває ну американці
вже давно наклали санкції на дубінського
і на багатьох покліічників у його
конкретно конкретно антиудержавницькій
роботі
а його всі адекватні люди в Україні
давно вважали людиною яка не має право
представляти їхні інтереси Ну але ж
Питання в тому що у нас є дуже багато
таких депутатів яких можна вважати і
державними зрадниками але які просто
просто-напросто виходять там з
монофракції І дальше виконують свою
якусь там дивну місію у Верховній Раді і
раз їх монофракція не відкликає не
застосовує ніякі інші засоби щоби їх не
було в найвищому законодавчому органі
держави значить вони чимось їм вигідні з
іншого боку я тішуся що нарешті хоч
зараз силовикам дійшли руки дослідити
знайти докази яких як на мене з 19-го
року було більше ніж достатньо щоби
притягати його до відповідальності Мені
би дуже хотілося щоб це не завершилося
тільки такою медійною афектацією А щоби
це завершилося дуже конкретними вироками
і щоби Це дало старт ще одній дуже
важливій тенденції яка на жаль не
спостерігається щоби нарешті у сесійну
залу винесли хоча би один з чотирьох а
бажано усі чотири законопроєкти які
забороніть депутатам із заборонених
партій брати участь представляти
українців як в Верховній Раді так і на
місцях я маю на увазі щоб ми позбулися
опзж та іншої гопкомпанії усіх радах
усіх рівнів ну це це це би мало статися
і це би мало статися якнайшвидше І до
речі Оце це це ще одна річ яку би
українці мали би сьогодні вимагати в той
час коли виходять е нас протестувальники
під різні органи місцевого
самоврядування протестувати проти того
чим займається Центральна Влада ну тобто
треба зміщувати акценти треба адресувати
проблеми державної ваги не місцевим
громадам А треба їх адресувати
безпосередньо банковій і не боятися це
робити І один з таки одна з таких вимог
щоби зрадники були притягнуті до
відповідальності